hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner tat
welt heute gibt es mal wieder eine
richtig coole torte ihr wisst ja ich
nehme ja gar keine aufträge an aber ich
habe jetzt anfang der woche einen
auftrag reinbekommen und wurde gefragt
ob ich nicht lust hätte eine coole
madagaskar torte zu machen und zwar
hatten staat die firma dreamworks
persönlich angeschrieben weil jetzt die
pinguine aus madagascar in die kinos
kommen
am 27.11 nämlich in allen kinos in
deutschland und da freuen wir uns schon
richtig drauf den film und die
madagaskar vielen wir sind übrigens
meine absoluten lieblingsfilme und
deswegen konnte ich da auch gar nicht
nein sagen ja wir gucken die zusammen
und nicht nur das ich jetzt heute ist
orten tutorial für euch habe ich habe
auch am ende des videos richtig coole
gewinne für euch ihr seht ihr schon an
unsere t-shirts und die firma dreamworks
hat uns da ganz viele sachen geschickt
die dürfen wir an euch verlosen und
deswegen bleibt am besten bis zum ende
dran und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal wie man diese torte macht bevor ich
jetzt mit der torte staaten muss
natürlich erst die deko hergestellt
werden
hier habe ich jetzt schwarzen fondant
genommen ihr könnt aber auch zum
beispiel schwarze lebensmittel passte
nehmen und diesen von dort muss man
natürlich mit cmc etwas verstärken damit
aus dem fondant einer modelliermasse
wird und ich gleich die figuren formen
kann und diese dann natürlich auch fest
werden denn von da an teile ich dann in
vier gleich große stücke
so hat jedes stück etwa 100 gramm und
jeder meiner pinguine wird etwa 100
gramm schwer
das sind relativ große pinguine aus den
portionen muss man jetzt jeweils eine
kugel formen und diese dann länglich
formen wie so einen kleinen zylinder und
da schaut ihr euch am besten die
pinguine in der vorlage an also einfach
ein bild anschauen und jeden pinguin so
formen wie eben gehört
hier seht ihr noch mal alle pinguinen
körper und zählt auch dass die ganz
unterschiedlich sind privat ist zum
beispiel ganz klein und die anderen eben
etwas länglicher und haben andere formen
die pinguine müssen jetzt einfach mal
durch trocknen und denen der
zwischenzeit bereit ich schon mal meine
ziegelsteine für die torte vor hier
verwende ich jetzt wieder von dorf in
rot ein und nehme dann wieder cmc pulver
dadurch ziegelsteine werden muss ich
natürlich auch verschiedene rottöne
benutzen und mische mir einfach die
farbe aus rot schwarz grün und blau
die modelliermasse rolle ich dann mit
hilfe meiner auswahl stäbchen auf 3 mm
aus und schneidet dann die ziegel zu
recht diese sollen einen zentimeter
breit und 15 cm lang sein
das geht am besten mit einem lineal und
einem messer aber ihr könnt auch anderes
werkzeug dafür benutzten die
ziegelsteine könnt ihr dann ganz einfach
durch trocknen lassen und bis zur
weiterverarbeitung aufheben
meine pinguin das sind jetzt etwas
getrocknet nach zwei drei tagen
und jetzt vorm ich aus weißer blüten
passte den weißen körper
den kann ich einfach mit hilfe von etwas
zucker kleber ankleben und in form
drücken
zuerst mit den fingern und dann nehme
ich mir noch ein bisschen modell ihr
werkzeug und kann dann die gesichtszüge
einfach auch rein formen und da schaue
ich natürlich auch wieder auf meine
vorlage
hier werde ich jetzt noch mit dem ball
tool die vertiefungen für die augen
reindrücken und formen mit dann aus
blüten passte zwei kleine kugel und
klebe die wieder mit zucker kleber in
die vertiefungen 1
nabel forme ich auch aus blüten passte
die ich vorher orange eingefärbt habe
und klebe ihn dann auch mit etwas zucker
kleber an
auch hier ist wieder jeder schnabel bei
mir anders weil jeder pinguin seinen
eigenen schnabel hat dann werden jetzt
noch die arme geformt ebenfalls aus
schwarzer blüten passte die habe ich
einfach schwarz eingefärbt bevor die
arme jetzt daran geklebt werden klebe
ich noch die augen dran in der
zwischenzeit können die arme schon mal
und bisher an trocknen und dann ist das
ankleben umso einfacher bei den
pinguinen könnt ihr jetzt noch akzente
im gesicht setzen und so ein bisschen
gestik und mimik hervorheben in dem ihr
noch augenbrauen mit einfügt hier habe
ich es jetzt aus blüten passte gemacht
und man sieht einfach auch gleich dass
das gesicht ganz anderen ausdruck
bekommt ihr könnt diese gesichtszüge
aber auch mit einem lebensmittel stift
machen der hier ist jetzt von deco back
damit geht es natürlich einfacher und
viel schneller rico bekommt jetzt bei
mir noch eine kleine haarpracht die habe
ich jetzt auch aus blüten passte gemacht
und jetzt kann ich hier noch die füße
formen und zwar braucht man dafür zwei
kleine kugeln die dann zu einem tropfen
geformt und platt gedrückt werden und
dann schneidet man mit einem messer oder
mit einer schere so dreiecke rein und
kann dann die füße einfach formen und
diese am besten dann auf eine platte
setzen und den pinguin draufsetzen und
diese fixiere ich dann auch mit etwas
zucker kleber und lasse einfach an
trocknen
mittlerweile sind auch die arme etwas
durchgetrocknet und ich kann sie auch
festkleben und diese werde ich jetzt
auch ein bisschen stützen mit
holzklötzen oder einfach mit ein paar
gegenständen aus der küche bis die
pinguin arme eben komplett ausgetrocknet
sind
wer möchte kann den schnabel jetzt noch
mit bisschen lebensmittel pulver farbe
einfach kontrollieren und die pinguine
sind dann fertig bei mir geht es jetzt
weiter mit der straßenlaterne dafür habe
ich mir einen kick pop stick genommen
und habe ihn in schwarzen blüten pasta
eingepackt und diese einfach lang
gerollt so dass es eben gleichmäßig drum
herum liegt dieser starb muss dann erst
mal durch trocknen für die einzelheiten
nehme ich mir jetzt hier meine clay
extruder und zwar hatte ich ja früher
diese suker gang mit der ich das machen
konnte mittlerweile habe ich jetzt den
extruder weil ich damit viel einfacher
arbeiten kann
hier seht ihr ein paar verschiedene
scheiben die man einsetzen kann
dann schraubt man diese scheiben vorne
an das gerät dran
hinten kann man dann etwas blüten passte
zum beispiel rein formen die man vorher
natürlich weich knetet und dann kann ich
mit drehenden bewegungen das gerät
verschließen und die paste vorne raus
drücken und es geht wirklich sehr
einfach man muss nämlich nur drehen und
muss nicht wie bei der show kagan
drücken wo das dann hängen bleibt
sondern hier geht es ganz einfach raus
ich kann dann bei der gewünschten länge
einfach abschneiden und zb auch während
dem vorgang die klingeln ganz einfach
wechseln und kann ebenso verschiedene
stränge heraus spritzen
ich habe jetzt hier dicke und dünne
strenge vorbereitet und werde diese dann
an meinen laterne und starb dran kleben
um einfach ein paar einzelheiten
run zu machen
als nächstes möchte ich jetzt oben die
laterne fertig machen und habe mir
einfach 4
trapeze auf dem papier aufgemalt und
zwischen backpapier gelegt und jetzt
nehme ich auch david dem claim extruder
und war jetzt die rahmen und werdet die
aneinander festkleben
diese rahmen müssen dann erst mal ein
bisschen durch trocknen wie sich sie
weiter verwenden kann
für das glas nehme ich mir etwas isomalt
und schmerzt es in der pfanne
das ist so ein bestimmter zucker der
eben nicht gleich karamellisiert und
einfach schön hell bleibt den verlinke
ich euch in meiner infobox und damit
kann ich jetzt die fenster aus gießen
und einfach erhärten lassen
nach dem aushärten lege ich sehe oben
zusammen und krebs sie fest unten habe
ich jetzt ein quadrat aus blüten passte
ausgeschnitten und darauf eben diese
trapeze befestigt mit einer spritze
stelle ich mir jetzt noch einen kreis
aus und klebe da noch eine kleine kerze
reihen die habe ich aus orangefarbene
und gelbe blüten passte hergestellt und
kann das dann auf diese laterne
aufkleben so dass ich in der laterne
jetzt eine leuchtende brennende kerze
habe
das muss jetzt natürlich komplett aus
herten und dieses könnt ihr auch bereits
schon 45 tage vorher machen
meine kinder sind jetzt fertig und auch
die ziegelsteine sind schon fertig und
bis zum tag des verkehrs sind es bei uns
noch drei tage
und deswegen werde ich jetzt heute
beginnen die böden zu backen und die
torten zu befüllen und bei uns gibt es
einen leckeren schokoladigen schober
teig mit nachweisen füllung also mit ner
sahne quark creme und so etwas früchte
mit drin und ich werde euch jetzt
einfach mal zeigen was ich für die
zutaten verwende das wird jetzt bei mir
eine zweistöckige torte ich zeige euch
aber jetzt nur das obere stockwerk und
schreib einfach auf meinem blog die
zutaten für das untere stockwerk einfach
damit das video jetzt nicht zu lange
wird
ich fange jetzt gleich meine toten in
diesen runden butt rahmen ihr könnt auch
spielformen benutzen natürlich und bei
mir werden
das ist erstmal vier bösen das heißt ich
benutze jetzt weil ich eben so viele da
aber für solche typen ringe aber ihr
könnt doch einfach die hälfte des
rezepts machen und erst mal im zwei
backen oder ihr packt einfach die halbe
menge in einem rahmen und bugs ganze
daneben zweimal hintereinander das geht
natürlich auch und zwar sind es jetzt
hier meine zutaten und ich benutze jetzt
hier vier eier 200 gramm zucker 200
gramm öl da habe ich jetzt ein
sonnenblumenöl wans geschmacksneutral
ist 200
am wasser das ist jetzt ein sprudelndes
mineralwasser ihr könnt aber auch saft
oder limonade oder likör oder irgendwas
nehmen 200 gramm mehl das habe ich jetzt
nicht gesiegt weil ich ein ganz feines
mehl ist wieder das von globus aber wenn
ihr ein anderes megaposter 750 gramm
kakaopulver 50 g speisestärke eine
packung backpulver und für den geschmack
nämlich jetzt noch ein bisschen vanille
konzentrat das ist natürlich jetzt in öl
eingelegt und alkoholfrei und ich werde
den tag gleich einfärben weil ich einen
schwarz-weißen kuchen möchte und nehmen
diese deko back passten farbe und wir
werden jetzt gleich den teig zubereiten
aber bevor ihr das macht solltet ihr
euch eure backwaren und vorbereiten ich
habe sie jetzt bereits schon in
backpapier eingeschlagen das verhindert
einfach dass da der teig ausläuft zuerst
geben wir jetzt die eier in die
rührschüssel da kommt jetzt der zucker
mit dazu und das ganze lassen wir jetzt
richtig schön cremig rühren das kann so
etwa fünf minuten dauern
ich gebe jetzt gleich noch ein bisschen
von dem vanille konzentrat dazu das
ganze ein paar tropfen
das reicht nämlich schon und das riecht
dann auch schon richtig lecker nach
manila
jetzt geben wir die flüssigkeiten mit
rein also öl
das hören wir jetzt ganz kurz unter bei
der niedrigsten stufe
und jetzt gebe ich da auch direkt die
farbe mit reimen denn ich bin jetzt
sowieso nur schwarz und muss den teig
nicht aufteilen
also kommt jetzt direkt betreuen müssen
natürlich jetzt wieder die azur freien
farben
jetzt geben wir hier durch den sieg das
kakaopulver die stärke das mehl und das
backpulver gibt es mit dem tragschrauber
kurz und jetzt vorziehen ihre ich meinen
tag auf meiner vier vermissten
und die tage werden jetzt so bei 170
grad ober und unterhitze für ungefähr 20
bis 30 minuten gebacken
es kommt einfach darauf an ob wir jetzt
die einfache menge oder die doppelte
menge in der form habt die stäbchen
probe wird auf jeden fall sagen ob der
teig durch ist während der teig jetzt
noch kenne ich schon mal meine
schokocreme zubereiten meine kanal
schmidt da nämlich später die torte dann
ein streichen und dafür habe ich jetzt
hier schon mal 200 gramm schlagsahne in
meinem job werde sie jetzt einmal kurz
aufkochen und hier habe ich bereits 400
gramm peter kuvertüre klein gehackt ihr
könnt auch ganz einfach zeit mit der
schokolade nehmen
ich hatte jetzt einfach nur kuvertüre da
und die muss einfach doppelt so viel
sein wie die sahne weil ich einfach eine
feste creme haben möchte und sobald die
sahne kocht gebe ich jetzt die
schokolade rheinstadt den herd aus
untreue ist einfach so lange bis sich
die schokolade komplett aufgelöst hat
und du weißt du
klümpchen frei ist also wenn sie die
komplette schokolade aufgelöst hat
können was jetzt einfach mal um
jetzt gebe ich da einfach
drauf und lasse bei zimmertemperatur
abkühlen am besten in den kühlen raum
ich werde sie so in etwa drei stunden
wieder brauchen wenn man kuchen gebacken
und daneben auch gefüllt ist ihr könnt
auch über nacht stehen lassen aber bitte
nicht im kühlschrank sie sollen nämlich
nicht kalt werden sie sollen nur
zimmertemperatur haben und seine
konsistenz wie nutella krähen haben
meine garage sind fertig und die lasse
ich jetzt hier hinten abkühle
übrigens müsst ihr natürlich wenn er
jetzt die zweistündige torte macht
natürlich auch eine größere menge an
cash machen
da kommt es aber einfach drauf an was
ihr dann auch für eine füllung macht und
vidic ihr später die torte damit
bestreicht des praktischen und
grundrezept aber in meinem blog steht
dann auch noch mal die genaue menge die
ich gebraucht habe hier hinten seht ihr
meine tortenböden die sind auch bereits
abgekühlt und ich kann mich jetzt um die
füllung kümmern und zeigt euch da
einfach mal die zutaten
ich brauche hier 400 gramm schlagsahne
die ist richtig gut kalt 500 gramm
magerquark hier habe ich 40 gramm
puderzucker
ich nehme wieder etwas von meinem
vanille extrakt und bissle abgeriebene
zitronenschale das war natürlich eine
bio zitrone
hier habe ich etwas sommerbad das
brauche ich gleich um die creme etwas zu
festigen
ihr könnt natürlich auch zum festigen
etwas gaga oder zum beispiel gelatine
nehme aber ihr wisst ich nehm ganz gerne
sonderfahrt weil erstens man bekommt man
das auch im supermarkt so nebenbei
bemerkt und ich nehme es einfach ganz
gerne weil es rein pflanzlich ist und
ich habe einfach keine lange wartezeit
wenn die creme fertig ist die wird
nämlich direkt fest und ich kann sie
direkt an schneiden und
weiterverarbeiten und deswegen eignet
sich das für mich finde ich am besten
für susanne krems ich werde jetzt in
meine torte oder eine leckere frucht
einlage machen und braucht deswegen noch
ein bis h ein paar früchte und zwar habe
ich ziehe eine dose von diesen 40
hälften die sind bereits ab getroffen
bislang abgetrocknet dann habe ich hier
zwei gläser pfirsich maracuja saft und
hier eine tüte agile mit der welt ich
nämlich gleich dann diese creme festigen
und das ganze so richtig lecker als
frucht einlage machen und die frucht
einlage ist auch das erste was wir
gleich vorbereiten
ich gebe den saft jetzt komplett hier
einen topf gibt da die ak diene dazu und
für rührt es jetzt einfach ganz kurzes
filmchen 2 ist jetzt ruhig einfach so
lange bis das ganze auf kocht und lass
es dann zwei minuten lang weiterkochen
und während hier jetzt diese dieser
maracujasaft aufkocht kann ich schon mal
die sahne schlagen
und zwar muss ich jetzt zuerst die sahne
etwas anrühren und jetzt gebe ich hier
zwei teelöffeln salat mit rein und wenn
sie dann steif schlagen wenn die sahne
steif ist stelle ich sie ganz kurz in
den kühlschrank mein 40 saft ist jetzt
aufgekommen und ich hatte ihnen übrigens
in einen größeren topf weil mir der
kleine nämlich übergelaufen ist und das
finde ich jetzt hier einfach kurz um
damit es jetzt schneller abkühlen kann
das ist jetzt noch sehr schlüssig aus
aber sobald die ak tina jetzt gleich
wirkt wird das ganze fester und ich kann
jetzt auch schon mal meine 40 hälften
einfach klein würfeln können dann mit
einem messer machen oder wie hier
einfach mit entscheide gerät
und diese fertigen würfel gebe ich hier
jetzt auch mit dazu und das lasse ich
jetzt einfach auch kurz an der seite
stehen und mache mir da quarkcreme
weiter jetzt bin ich hier meinen quark
und gebt denen großes klar so eine große
schüssel
da kommt der puderzucker mit dazu und
auch gleich zwei teelöffel von dem
sommerbad ein bissle von dem vanille
extrakt dann die zitronenschale mit rein
und das ganze jetzt bei niedriger stufe
kurz verrühren
ich kann jetzt hier bereits meine sahne
unter die quarkmasse heben
ich bin jetzt bereit und kann meine
torte befüllen
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal was
vorbereitet und zwar habe ich hier unten
eine kupferplatte das ist so eine leicht
schaum platte und die habe ich schon im
durchmesser einer torte
zurechtgeschnitten
die gibt's auch übrigens bald bei uns im
shop jetzt allerdings noch nicht aber
man kann auch eine ganz normale ist so
ein kickboard nehmen oder sich zum
beispiel eine pappe zurechtschneiden auf
jeden fall ist es wichtig dass ihr jetzt
den kuchen beziehungsweise die torte auf
eine platte habt damit ihr sie eben
gleich weiterverarbeiten können
ich habe den kuchen mit dem bislicher
stolz drauf geklebt und habe meine
restliche danach jetzt erst mal hier in
spring in so einen spritzbeutel
eingefüllt einfach bei mir ich gleich
jetzt damit arbeiten kann um einen
tortenboden lege ich jetzt einen sprung
vom rand bzw einen torten rand und jetzt
stürzt sich hier einen rand außenrum mit
ghana einfach damit gleich meine sahne
creme nicht in verbindung mit dem vom
land kommt der rand ist hier ein bissle
fest geworden und jetzt gebe ich hier
meine sahne creme rein da muss ich
einfach aufpassen dass die sache jetzt
nicht an den rand kommt damit sie nicht
später an den von dort drankommt hier
kommt jetzt ein bissel von der
versicherung mit rein dann kommt jetzt
der zweite boden rein dann natürlich
wieder von dem garant und so machen wir
jetzt einfach weiter bis die komplette
creme aufgebraucht ist uns unsere torte
zusammen
und hier seht ihr es jetzt nochmal gut
ich habe in der mitte meine sahne creme
meine persische und außen herum nur
dieser kanal den nur kanals oder echte
buttercreme darf eben an den von dann
dran kommen und so habe ich jetzt meinen
von dort geschützt und kann trotzdem
jede beliebige creme benutzen
jetzt kommt mein deckel drauf das war
nämlich schon die letzte schicht und so
gebe ich jetzt den kuchen in den
kühlschrank für mindestens einen tag
damit er einfach schön fest wird die
garage kann richtig schön fest werden
und danach können wir gleich weiter
arbeiten jetzt bestreite ich meine torte
rundherum meter kanal schein
ihr seht die kanarische ist wirklich
sehr weich die torte ist sehr kalt und
deswegen fällt so das arbeiten leicht
die torte muss dann komplett klappt
eingestrichen werden und kann dann zum
schluss mit von dort eingedeckt werden
ich nehme es hier grauen von dort den
habe ich aus weiß und schwarz gemischt
und rolle denn richtig schön rund aus
das geht am besten auf etwas becker
stärke und mit einem ausfall stab aus
silikon die torte muss jetzt noch
komplett glatt gestrichen werden das
halte ich jetzt hier relativ kurz weil
ich da schon einige videos dazu gemacht
habe und anschließend kann ich die torte
dann einfach wieder kühl stellen
und auch die eckige torte habe ich auf
die gleiche weise hergestellt und habe
sie dann einfach kühl gestellt
jetzt möchte ich diese torte mit den
steinchen hätte kurieren ich habe hier
meine fertigen kleine und die sind jetzt
auch alle richtig schön fest und hart
und ich werde das jetzt einfach mit
etwas racing ankleben also mit einem mit
einer zucker sprits glasur und dafür
habe ich jetzt hier 125 gramm
puderzucker
ich habe wasser und ich nehme dafür
eiweißpulver natürlich könnt ihr auch
ein frisches und rohes ei weiß benutzen
aber da hat man natürlich immer die
gefahr mit rom ein weißes möchte auch
nicht jeder
und ich mache es einfach mit eiweiß
pulver als auch viel schneller geht das
eiweißpulver verlinke ich euch auch in
meiner infobox und davon brauche ich
jetzt eineinhalb esslöffel sowohl
hineinnehmen öl wie viele euro und wenn
ihr ein hoppala
wenn ihr nehmt dann braucht ihr ein ei
und 250 gramm puderzucker oder enthalten
ein halbes ei was er vorher eben das
eiweiß verquirlt und dann könnt ihr die
hälfte davon wegnehmen
jetzt brauche ich noch drei esslöffel
wasser und das ist so ziemlich die
einfachste methode um realizing
herzustellen und jetzt nehme ich noch
mal ein bisschen von dem schwarz
und jetzt kann man die steine an die
torte kleben wir fangen jetzt unten an
und mauern nach oben
also so wie man auch wirklich mauern und
gehen nach oben
und jetzt können wir einfach die steine
ankleben einfach unten mit der ersten
reihe beginnen und einfach irgendwie
ankleben
man kann da jetzt natürlich auch die
spritz glasow dicke drauf machen dass
wenn man die steine jetzt rein drückt
das er dann sind vor quillt aber dann
hat man natürlich auch viel mehr zucker
in dem in der torte oder auf der torte
und ob man das dann eben will muss man
selber entscheiden
und wenn die erste reihe gemacht ist
beginnen wir mit der zweiten und wollte
genau das weiß ich wirklich nur mal so
und die zweite reihe wir gehen wir
einfach versetzt
für den eckigen kuchen bereit ich mir
jetzt hier wieder schwarzen von dorf und
gebt den jetzt durch die nudelmaschine
damit einfach dünn und gleichmäßig
ausgerollt wird und schneide mir jetzt
aus schwarz und weiß gleichmäßige
streifen
diese haben bei mir eine breite von 25
cm und haben die höhe meiner torte plus
etwa 5 cm rechts und links kleben bei
mir jetzt schwarze streifen die nur die
hälfte der breite haben also 125 cm und
diese streifen legt ihr jetzt einfach
nebeneinander und pinsel sie dann mit
etwas zucker kleber
das ganze habe ich jetzt mit der wachs
papier methode gemacht also einfach die
streifen auf dem wachs papier
zusammengesetzt und dann mit hilfe eines
buches oder eines anderen flachen
gegenstands auf die torte drangesetzt
erst müsst ihr hier jetzt die zwei
gegenüberliegenden seiten an bringen und
dann die zwei übrigen seiten und hier
muss man einfach darauf achten dass man
jetzt diagonal die streifen weg
schneidet das geht natürlich am besten
wenn man auch hier etwas wachs papier zu
hilfe nimmt damit die anderen
geschichten jetzt nicht dreckig werden
wenn das dann alles erledigt ist könnt
ihr die zwei torten jetzt stapeln
ich habe jetzt in der unteren torte
bereits ein paar torten dübel drin
falls ihr nicht wisst was ich meine
schaut einfach mal bei meinem trocken
video vorbei und ich kann jetzt die
restliche deko anbringen
auf der oberfläche der runden torte
setze ich jetzt noch zwei kreise aus
sondern drauf und werde diese mit einer
spritztour mit einem loch vorne einfach
strukturieren
zum schluss wird jetzt nur noch die deko
auf die torte gesetzt ich habe jetzt
hier wie es sehen können schon mal
meinen schriftzug draus gemacht ich hab
den schriftzug einfach auch so opladen
gemalt ich beziehe zwar die runden in
der handarbeits hatte ecke geht zum
drauf male und habe sie einfach mit
lebensmittel farbstiften drauf gemalt
das sind jetzt übrigens auch welche von
deco back als nächstes kann ich jetzt
meinen meine laterne draufkleben gebe
ich jetzt hier einfach ein bisschen
kleber drauf und setzt jetzt die laterne
einfach drauf
ich kann jetzt die pinguine ankleben
zuerst nehme ich mir jetzt mal den
anführer natürlich er bekommt seinen
platz ganz vorne
klaus gilt der große
rücken an rücken jessica so früh los ist
jetzt auch cool aus und haben hier der
kleine privat eigentlich es bedarf so
eine flips tüte daneben machen wer sich
den film anschaut weiß auch warum und
rico so schatz du siehst von vorne wo
soll ricco hin so dazu ich habe jetzt
meine torte fertig gebacken nach ein
paar stunden arbeit und so sieht sie
jetzt aus ihr seht es nicht richtig cool
aus vor allen dingen mit dieser lampen
der mitte und ich habe jetzt diese obere
stockwerk gleich zwei mal gemacht und
zeigt ihr habt einfach mal ganz kurz den
anschnitt
damit ihr auch seht wie das innenleben
aussieht und so sieht man das
schwarz-weiße pinguin torte aus und ihr
seht es ist ein richtig schöner feuchte
teig und eine sehr leckere creme aber
jetzt genug zur torte kommen wir zum
gewinnspiel von dreamworks fünf tolle
pakete bekommen und zwar sieht jedes
päckchen gleich aus ich habe eine
brotbox eine isolierte asche ich habe
hier eine tasse keinen stress ball und
ein t-shirt das habt ihr vorhin schon
gesehen und zwei kinokarten für ganz
deutschland also ihr könnt da ab dem 27
in die kinos mit diesen zwei partner
dieses zeit habe ich jetzt fünf mal und
ich habe jetzt auch natürlich noch in
meiner region mich umgehört und habe in
den kinos in der umgebung nachgefragt
und zwar 10 setzt drei kinos aus meiner
region aus bruchsal und aus mannheim
insgesamt sind es drei stück die liesel
ebay ersteigert hat sich noch nicht bei
mir gemeldet und hat für jedes kino zehn
karten klar gemacht also fünfmal zwei
tickets das heißt falls ihr jetzt aus
meiner region seit aus bruchsal oder aus
mannheim oder einfach eine kurze anfahrt
dahin habt könnt ihr jetzt auch in die
kommentare reinschreiben dass ihr diese
fünf mal zwei tickets gewinnen wollte
gewinnen natürlich nur zwei tickets und
ihr müsst
in den kommentaren reinschreiben was ihr
gerne haben möchte also ob ihr jetzt das
deutschlandweit haben möchte oder das
mannheimer oder das bruchsaler set
schreibt mir bei youtube in die
kommentare schreibt mir auch bei
facebook in die kommentare
und ihr könnt es auch bei facebook gerne
noch teilen müssen darauf achten dass
ihr das ganze öffentlichkeit damit ich
sehe dass ihr geteilt habt dann kommt
ihr nämlich gleich zweimal in den topf
und ich würde jetzt einfach mal sagen
mein rezept zum nachlesen auf sallys -
blog.de da gibt es die ganz genaue
anleitungen für die komplette torte und
ich freue mich schon auf eure
rückmeldung und hoffe dass ihr euch über
die gewinne freuen
mir hat auf jeden fall ganz viel spaß
gemacht diese torte zu backen
ich wünsche euch jetzt noch ganz viel
spaß hoffe dass ihr mir eine bewertung
da läuft und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder